okay so now we have the wireframes
implemented for both screens but what
does it look like on the tablet well
unfortunately when we take the phone UI
and stretch it out on a tablet it
doesn't look that great there's a lot of
empty white space here we could better
take advantage of this screen real
estate by showing more useful
information for example why do the
details need to be a tap away when they
could just as easily fit on this screen
and furthermore if the user wants to
look through the full list of forecasts
their eyes must go like this which is an
unpleasant reading experience if we want
the user to read some content we should
keep the width narrower so that they can
scan it quickly these considerations are
part of responsive design responsive
design means designing your app by
keeping in mind that it will be used
across a range of different device
screen sizes how do we do that and what
does it mean to build for larger screen
devices like tablets well I can show you
some examples of how apps adopt using
multi-pane layouts in the Android design
guide there's a section on multi-pane
layouts one technique is to combine
multiple views together for example in
the people app you have the contact list
and the contact card for additional
details on the tablet we can put them
side-by-side this is also known as the
master detail flow this is the master
list and this is the detail pane in the
Settings app we have another example the
column width adjusts based on the
available screen width in the calendar
app we have panels and they stack
vertically in the portrait orientation
but horizontally in the landscape
orientation there are also a couple
other examples that you can look through
as well if you want more information on
designing for tablets or responsive
design in general you can check out the
links below for more details in this
course we're learning how to build up
the phone UI first and then the tablet
UI but in reality when we are designing
it we thought about responsive design
from day one when you're building your
own app it's bad practice to just
completely design and build your phone
app and then start to brainstorm about
the tablet UI that's because the tablet
UI often has an impact on the phone
design as well as the architectural
decisions made here